today I'm going to share with you 10
things that I spend more money on after
having adopted a minimist lifestyle and
these are things that I spend without
feeling any guilt without feeling shame
and that I'm happy to put my money
towards and I'm super excited for this
video because I have definitely made
lots of videos on ways to save money
things that I've cut out for my life uh
things that I no longer own or buy and I
think that when we hear the message of
minimalism we can often think of being
void of things and removing things from
our life and while I think it was super
helpful to declutter to quit negative
habits in order to be able to see what I
value it really ultimately led me to a
trap of feeling guilty and feeling shame
when it is that I purchased something or
when I wanted to buy something and I
think that it can be super hard to kind
of find that distinction of I want to
save money I want to be uh responsible
with my money I want to be a good
Steward but then I also want to be able
to enjoy my money I want to be able to
put it towards things that add value to
my life this video is not meant in any
way to say that we should just put
everything on our credit cards or that
we should just go to the Other Extreme
and not spend spend any money but rather
it's to kind of hopefully share the
message that money is a tool whenever I
think of the way that I spend my money
more intentionally it really adds a lot
more value to my life and I feel no
guilt in spending money in certain areas
so today I'll share those with you but
keep in mind that some of these may not
apply to you and that's the beauty of it
is that it's definitely personal to you
to your values to your hobbies to your
likes and dislikes we shouldn't really
fall into these traps of going to those
extremes and I've definitely gone to
both ends of extremes and minimalism
where I've purchased things and I've
spent money for the aesthetic of
minimalism for getting what it really
means and then I've also gone to the
other end where I've talked about like
feeling the guilt and feeling the shame
because I spent something or bought
something or a shame from other people
like and you're a minimalist and you
bought this I've definitely gotten that
as well so I definitely think it's
helpful to talk about what we remove and
what we want to stop but I don't want to
forget that aspect that money is meant
to be used it's meant to to ultimately
result in positive changes and as Dave
Ramsey says money can be a lot of fun
you can help out a lot of people in some
very creative and awesome ways when you
have money I don't want to feel guilty
any longer for spending money and
there's a lot of things in my life that
I've realized I'm happier because I
spend money on these areas and I don't
have any guilt or shame in saying that
so hopefully this video will be helpful
to you if you like me have experienced
the guilt or the shame or being shamed
by other people but hopefully we can do
this in a way that's more intentional so
we're not putting things on our credit
card but we're actually thinking about
the longterm as well as our hopes our
dreams the things that we enjoy first up
is subscriptions I really wanted this to
be the first one because I felt like I'm
going to sound like a total hypocrite
when I say this and it's because I've
mentioned that if you want to save money
cut off your subscriptions and while I
still agree with that there are some
caveats to that the way that I think
about my subscriptions are one of two
different ways are they meant to make me
a Creator or are they meant to make me a
consumer conser so just to give you the
example in the past I had a music
subscription we had Netflix we had Hulu
we had other things that were meant to
make me consume other people's media
that really weren't helping me in the
long run I mean when I would watch
Netflix I would watch kramas and really
binge watching for 2: 3: in the morning
and for what like it really didn't make
me any better of a person now I'm happy
to put my money towards subscriptions
that are helping me to improve in some
way to learn something to be healthier
so for example in the summertime we had
a subscription for a gym that had a pool
and my kids love that I've since
canceled it cuz I like to out at home
but it was awesome to be able to use the
pool during the summertime and get the
kids out I do also have a subscription
for simply piano which is what I've been
using and what my daughter's been using
in order to learn how to play the piano
I'm not sponsored by them but just just
to give you an example this is something
that I'm happy to spend my money on for
two different reasons one I always
wanted to learn the piano but because I
homeschool them I didn't want for them
to miss out on something that they would
otherwise have in a public school so I
think that subscriptions can be very
helpful but there is that distinction
are they meant to make you a consumer or
are they meant to make you a Creator or
even just in the example of a gym if
it's something that you are using that
you're getting value out of that you're
feeling stronger and healthier it's
improving you I think of it as an
investment in myself and all the other
subscriptions that are really just meant
to make me a consumer I have completely
eliminated number two is coffees and
teas I have been a huge lover of lattes
for many years I think really ever since
I was in college and I tried the frappes
and the lattes and the cappuccinos and
all those little cafes I just fell in
love with cafes going to coffee shops
and having different drinks I love love
love me a warm drink and when I was kind
of starting to remove more things from
my life and really adopt more minimalism
I thought about should I just cut this
habit from my life completely and for
context I've never really been addicted
to caffeine I actually always drink
decaf anyway so it's not like I'm
missing the the coffee for me it's the
warm drink it's the experience of having
the mug in my hand and sipping it slowly
and enjoying and savoring that drink and
I was thinking of I should just cut it
off for my life and that'll be easier I
won't even need any of that and it's not
a necessity but my husband and I
actually went out and purchased an
espresso machine I think it's been like
a year year and a half now that we've
had it and I'm so glad that we did
because even though we spent more money
on this machine that yes definitely was
an expensive purchase up front now I
don't go to the coffee shops but I have
this habit that brings me a lot of joy
that makes me excited to wake up in the
morning and when I kind of think about
why I wanted to cut it out for my life I
think it really ultimately I have to be
honest with myself and admit that it's
because I see all these other people
that live off their backpacks and need
very little and part of me admires them
admires that they need so little and
they're so content and so happy with
just few items but for me why would I
cut off something from my life that does
make me happy that genuinely just brings
me so much joy so for me that's one of
those areas that I just I can't I mean I
can I can cut it off for my life but I
don't see a value or reason why I should
I'm definitely going to continue
drinking my lattes number three is books
and audio books I love physical books it
was really really hard for me to
actually declutter a lot of my books
because to me they're just a Sentimental
item they're really hard to let go of
cuz I find like they're like gold
they're valuable people spent so many
hours into creating this that I have in
my hands and it's like their knowledge
condensed into one but I have since
donated a lot of our books to our local
library and I figure what an awesome way
to be able to declutter this because now
if I ever want to read those books again
I can just check them out from my
library and read them again and in the
meantime other people can enjoy them but
now that I don't have as many physical
books I generally go towards audiobooks
or just ebooks in general I've gifted a
lot of people different books that I've
Loved through audiobooks especially
through Audible for example because some
people don't really love reading or they
might not really take the time to go
through it and for me being able to
spread that message through an audiobook
has been super helpful because that way
it's something that you can do when
you're driving in the car when you're
washing the dishes when you're vacuuming
the house I'm a huge fan of audiobooks
and the platform that I use for that is
Audible and I love them because the apps
like hoopla and Libby that I can have
books through my local library often
don't have the newer titles available
Audible has an incredible selection of
books and I actually have a link down
below for a free 30-day trial as well as
a free audio book yours to keep even if
you cancel the book that I'm Rel
listening to Curr ly is the empowered
wife by Laura Doyle and I love it hands
down recommended to any woman who is
married or wanting to get married I just
have found it of immense value so check
out Audible and if you want to check out
that book let me know what you think
this next one is a simple one we have
filtered water we have a berky filter
but we also actually installed uh like a
whole house water filter it was super
helpful because we both my daughter and
I have eczema and in the summertime it
just I don't know the humidity of it
kind of makes us flare out and and in
the winter time water can be really
drying but hot water for us it burns
like it hurts our skin it just makes it
super dry and it was really really
irritating her eczema was really really
bad when she was younger so we installed
a whole house water filter and I
definitely noticed that it helped her I
don't know that it necessarily like made
my hair any better I I know I've heard a
lot of people say like oh water filter
for your shower like it's it's the bomb
I don't know that I really noticed that
much but I definitely noticed that it
improved my skin like it just didn't
feel as harsh on my skin and then just
having a water filter in the home I mean
you're not buying water like all the
time or buying cases of water bottles or
gallons or whatever so on that end it
can definitely save a lot of money just
to have a filter buy it up front and
then don't ever have to buy water
bottles again I love our berky filter
because it's very high quality it's very
efficient and just to me the value that
it provides in having safe clean
drinking water is just so so helpful I
recently saw a video and I I don't
remember the name of the doctor but he
was talking about how for women
especially a lot of the chemical that
are in tap water can affect our hormones
and how our hormones affect everything I
mean a menstrual cycle is something that
we don't really hear a lot about we
don't learn a lot about and it can
affect our daily life so taking care of
my hormones my daughter's hormones just
the men in my life as well is something
that I think is very important so having
clean water to me is totally worth the
money this next one is one that I never
used to spend money on and it's in the
realm of skincare sunscreen in my 20s I
had lots and lots of sunspots and used
to just do full on full face makeup
because I really felt kind of insecure
about them but I never realized that
this was my doing like I always thought
they were kind of like just moles that I
just had I don't know because I had the
biology of it and I went to a
dermatologist when I was like 28 and
they lasered off 42 sunspots like moles
and after that I was very very very
diligent to wear sunscreen and I was so
much happier having had more of a clean
complexion skin tone and I I wanted to
preserve that I wanted to take care of
that I didn't feel guilty at all
spending the money to laser them off
because it was something that made me
feel insecure in the past and now I want
to take care of my skin now that I'm in
my 30s I realize man I never ever ever
took care of my skin I would just go out
in the sun full full on sun and stay all
day turn red as a tomato never put on
sunscreen never put on a hat because I
felt like well I'm tan I'm Mexican we
don't get skin cancers like it doesn't
matter I'm fine yeah well now down the
road I care about that and I want to
maintain my skin I'm not like doing
injections or anything like that
anything major but I do want to just
take care of my skin so that I age
gracefully and also prevent skin cancer
of course so this is something that I'm
now happy to spend money on next up is
nutrition and supplements this one is
one that stem from when I was introduced
to the vegan diet and I really started
to care a whole lot more about what went
into my body and what chemicals I'm
consuming and just junk that I was
putting into my body and y'all I'm not a
vegan I'm totally a carnivore raised by
far Farmers not ashamed to admit that I
did clean keto and I shared all about
what I ate and what I did but I do
really really really value Nutrition a
whole lot more than I ever did thanks to
having experienced going through the
vegan diet and changing the way that I
was eating I was eating a lot of junk
food a lot of fast food and never really
cared about what went into it and I
realized I'm not getting any younger and
even though I'm in my 30s and I feel
healthy and I thank God that I don't
have any like chronic ailments or
anything like that ultimately like our
bodies are meant to deteriorate and I
want to be healthy for as long as
possible to feel my best for as long as
possible so it's really up to me to be
able to provide my body with the
nutrients that I need and the
supplements as well so to me that's an
area where I think of it as an
investment there is no sense in making a
ton of money and being a millionaire
being a billionaire if I don't have the
health to enjoy that so I definitely
want to yes save money but I want to
Value prioritizing my health as well
because I think if we can be super super
skimpy I've definitely known people that
have skimped out because frugality and
they just really really want to be cheap
but then they don't spend it towards
their own health and their own body and
then they're paying it back in doctor
bills because they're sick because they
didn't want to invest that money in
themselves so this is an area that for
me I feel very very strongly about I am
okay not only okay but passionate about
investing money into my health and
providing my body with the nutrients
that it needs and it doesn't even have
to be super extreme I definitely shared
a video on what I eat in a day so you
can check that out and see what it is
that I typically eat but uh yeah
nutrients supplements something that I
highly value next up is tools or
equipment that improve your efficiency
or work outcomes so for example when my
husband was first starting off in a new
job in construction he felt really
guilty about spending money on tools and
he would always want to like buy the
cheaper stuff and buy the cheaper tools
and I would always tell him what my dad
had always said growing up and he would
say I buy the expensive thing once so
that I don't ever have to buy it again
not in saying that the thing that's
worth more money is always better cuz
it's not it's often not but just in the
sense that when you buy the good quality
item when you buy that item that yes
might be a little bit more upfront you
often end up with a more efficient job a
better we or a more well better done a
more well done my goodness my grammar I
need to go back to school y'all a more
well done job and in the terms of
YouTube for example when my camera broke
and I couldn't fix it I tried to trouble
shoot it and I tried to do all that I
could to save it my husband went back
and he applied the same logic to me even
though I felt guilty I didn't want to
spend money y'all I'm still in the red
I've spent thousands on this YouTube
channel and I have yet to make that
money back but he encouraged me and he
like I said he's always been my
cheerleader he said well if you plan on
doing this for a while buy the one
that's going to last you for years down
the road buy the one that's going to be
able to open doors for you to be able to
do a live stream or do whatever and I
listen even though I felt really really
guilty I was like man I'm spending so
much money and I bought the Sony 7c and
I bought a really good lens and I am so
excited about that because I can see a
huge difference in quality of my videos
now from before I had the camera and
even when I purchased Final Cut Pro I
was also not wanting to do that and he
was my encouragement he was like saying
this is something that's going to help
you make better videos than do it and I
am so glad that I listened because when
I got that my editing was so much faster
so I was more efficient and my quality
was better not just buying for the sake
of buying because I'm not like telling
you that you need to buy a whole bunch
of equipment that's not what I've done
I've definitely done my research to try
to find the least amount of equipment
that I need that will last me for a
while so this is an area that I'm glad
that we do invest in because it saves us
a lot of Heartache in the long run but
I'm definitely not giving advice because
like I said I'm still definitely in the
red with this YouTube channel so if you
want to support my channel and give it a
thumbs up I would highly appreciate that
this next one is one that I'm very
passionate about and is giving and Gifts
in general I don't really hear a lot of
people talking about spending more money
on gifts or giving and it's something
that to me I really want to talk about
this not because I want to toot my own
horn and say like oh yese is so giving
she's so awesome not at all actually
because I was not the most giving person
to me giving was very hard I definitely
had a scarcity mindset around money I
felt like if I would remove my money
spend my money I felt guilty if I gave
my money I felt that maybe that person
would want to take advantage of me that
other people would come to me asking me
for money CU it does happen but I am so
so so glad that I've met my husband that
he is just the most giving person
actually I think he's second my mom is
the most giving person that I know but
he is he's a close second and I'm so so
glad that he has been just such an
encouragement to me and giving not being
afraid of giving giving even when you're
scarce even when you have little because
when you give even when you have little
to give and you give it out of love oh
my goodness the way that you receive in
ways that are so unexpected is
incredible it just leaves me in awe and
being able to prioritize cutting things
out for my life not spending so much
money on those things that I don't need
that aren't suiting me that aren't
helping me be a better person I don't
really do a lot of things that I used to
do that money is now things that I can
spend towards helping other people
towards gifting other people and I'm not
going to say the ways in which we've
done so but some of the ways that we've
been able to bless other people is just
to me it leaves me in awe and it leaves
me so thankful because I wouldn't be
able to have helped the people that I've
helped if it weren't for having adopted
a minimalist lifestyle if it weren't for
having remove those negative habits and
yes I do want to spend money on myself
and I want to be able to buy things that
I want uh like the Pano subscription for
example or having Audi books but I also
don't want it just to be about me
because if it's just about me that I'm
not going to have fulfillment in my life
I'm not going to have that joy that love
and it definitely radiates into
everything whenever you give freely it
really just opens up more love in your
life and I think it opens you up to
receive more so giving is something that
I could definitely talk about in a whole
another video but to me removing other
things from my life has allowed me to
have more budget in order to gift in
order to bless others and ah it's just
an incredible blessing that goes right
back to me this next one is kind of
relevant to the prior one about tools
and equipment but this is just in
general I spend more money on higher
quality items versus cheap pieces of
crap so I'll give you an example we had
this pan that I thought was cast iron
but it was like brushed with something
something else and it didn't say what it
was brushed with and I after we've had
it for a while it was like flaking off
it was crusting where I was just left
asking my husband like God knows what we
have been eating recently because that
material is probably been ingested by us
and so we invested into lus and I'm so
glad that we did it has a your lifetime
warranty it's such good quality I'm now
not worried about the chemicals and
toxins that go into my body it's like
the one pan that I'm going to need
forever uh so we bought two pans but
it's now something that I'm not going to
have to constantly be replacing because
I had kept buying the cheap piece of
crap that God knows what I was even
eating off of that pan so I don't buy
like the cheap Teflon pans or anything
like that sometimes when it comes to
having one durable item that's going to
last you sometimes even a lifetime or
even more lifetimes cuz like in the
example of cast iron you can pass them
down for example I would much rather go
and purchase higher quality items but
higher quality items don't don't
necessarily have to mean that you spend
more money cuz you can get them
secondhand so you can definitely be
creative in the way that you have higher
quality items but I definitely
prioritize buying the better quality
over the cheap sale item just because it
was on sale this next one is one that I
admit I didn't ever really want to spend
money in the past it's local mom and
popop businesses I had never really
cared about spending money locally that
was not something that I really wanted
to do like the farmer shops and all
those things like that the farmers
markets I felt like they were more
expensive actually and I didn't want to
put my money towards that until recently
and we were able to get out of De debt
and I I really thought of my money
differently I visualized my money
differently I see it as something that
can not only be a blessing to me but can
be a blessing to others and even in the
way that I spend my money so going to
the locally owned shop and helping
support this one family versus this like
big multi-billion company that doesn't
even care about its employees some of
the time I would rather spend my money
towards those if I can actually I've
recently taken a break off of Amazon not
bashing Amazon but just because I felt
like I was constantly investing in
companies I don't even know what they
stand for and I'd rather go into
physical stores and help those local
businesses so in the example of my
supplements there's a local Mom and Pop
shop that sells supplements and they
have good quality stuff and I was buying
them off of Amazon from I don't even
know who so I would rather spend my
money towards helping not only get me
the things that I want and need but to
also help those local businesses as well
and yeah it may be a drive but I can do
it on my way to do something I get an
interaction out of it and I don't have
those boxes stacking up in my house and
and not to mention all the waste that
goes into people driving to packing them
bringing them to my home so I've
definitely enjoyed having my Amazon
break and last on the list is good
quality work I think that sometimes when
I try to save more money and I'm like
having that like no give it back like I
don't want to give my money away is when
I end up spending even more so just to
give you an example the mechanic shop
used to in the past we would go to these
like really cheap shops that would say
oh yeah I'll charge you this amount of
money for for your work but they didn't
offer a warranty often times they
wouldn't even find the problem or they
would fix it and then it would come
right back and now we spend money
towards going to The Trusted mechanic
shops that offer warranty that are more
expensive but they find the problem they
fix it if there's another problem they
will tell us up up front what it is and
they have a warranty on what it is that
they do so I'm definitely happier to
spend more money on the people that know
how to do their job that know how to do
it well and again it goes back to yes I
have a need I I need a good functioning
car right but I also want for my money
to be a blessing for the people that are
working hard that are doing what they're
supposed to be doing and that know what
they're doing and supporting their
business I think whenever we spend our
money and see our money differently when
we see that it can not only be a
blessing to us but we also think about
the other person and how can our money
not only bless us but other people as
well it's just it's a totally different
shift and it all comes back to you I
think it's definitely true that the
things that you focus on or the things
that you receive more and when you have
an abundance mindset when you don't have
fear or shame around money it just
becomes so much more easy to receive it
and not feel guilt and not feel shame
for it that's it for today's video These
are the 10 things that I spend more
money on after having adopted a
minimalist lifestyle if you haven't
already be sure to check out the
opposing video to this one the 10 things
that I refuse to spend my money on I'll
link it down below as well as put it up
here somewhere so that you can check it
out after this one and if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up and
help support my channel And subscribe so
you won't miss when I post a new video
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you in the next one bye for now